hello and welcome to a week nine edition
of the Beacher report fantasy football
show presented by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan establish the run.com as
always joined by Michael Leone of
establish the run.com how's it going
today Michael it's going pretty well how
are you
Adam could not be better as we approach
the Midway point of the NFL season
today's topic on the show is going to be
players to trade for we know a lot of
you have trade deadlines perhaps coming
up in your fantasy football league we're
going to give you guys some ideas on
players to consider trading for today of
course we'll do our State Farm bundles
before we get into all that
though quick love to the chat Marky Mark
asks starting will Levis and DeAndre
Hopkins tonight do I have a chance with
Levis as my quarterback this week well
Marky Mark that's a tough question to
answer without knowing the rest of your
team and your opponent's team however
from will Lev's perspective what I will
say is that this guy has a big arm as we
saw I think if you go to my Twitter if
you want to scroll back a little bit
Adam Levon all one word uh there's a
video there of every one of will Lev's
throws and I think what you'll see is
willingness to push the ball deep down
the field even in contested situations
and then also a lot of checkdowns also
not I think the cleanest spot against
Pittsburgh here for will Levis on the
road but yeah man I mean quarterback
distributions and I don't want to get
too nerdy here Leon quarterback
distributions are kind of uh clumped
together in other words the worst
quarterbacks are likely somewhere 13 14
points and the best ones are likely 20
21 points something like that so it's
unlikely you get killed at quarterback
but hey I played Lamar Jackson last week
and I lost by 25 points to Jaylen Herz
so you just never know uh but anyways
Leone what do you think about Levis is
outlooking yeah I mean I like the upside
we saw him throw for four touchdowns in
his first start which was kind of crazy
given that Ryan tanah Hill has thrown
two in six games this year in the same
offense so um he was still kind of like
a raw Prospect we saw him fall a good
bit in the first round so I'm you know
I'm skeptical I don't want to go too
overboard on one start but it was super
encouraging relatively what tan Hill has
been able to do so he's someone I've
picked up in Fab this week in a few of
my leagues as my quarterback too to kind
of ride that upside as you said not the
cleanest spot the team total here is
only like 177 for the tight end but you
know the the Steelers have had some
struggles in the secondary they've given
up like 7.1 yards per attempt which is
bottom third in the NFL so there's a
little bit of optimism for for Lis today
yeah I hope so okay let's move to the
players to trade for so these are going
to be players who you probably buying
low on for one reason or another we
think that these are players that are
actually someone your opponent would
give up you know I hate reading stuff
like go trade for Christian mcaffry
nobody's trading Christian mcaffrey all
right so let's start here players to
trade for we'll go first one Jonathan
Taylor now weird stuff last week with
Jonathan Taylor first half 11 carries 95
yards just shredding a pretty good
Saints defense second half Jonathan
Taylor only gets one carry and one
target Jonathan Taylor Shane styken both
say that was not injury related it's
just that Zach Moss has been playing
well and to their credit to defend them
Zach Moss has been playing well I mean
Zach Moss has been by any metric one of
the best running backs in the NFL this
year and so I feel like people are
getting sick of this time share between
JT and Zach Moss my take is that as the
year goes on the Gap in production in
Talent will start to show more between
Jonathan Taylor and Zach Moss not to
mention the fact that they just gave
this guy a huge
contract playing him behind Zach Moss or
even with Zach Moss doesn't look good
there so I like think of adding JT here
Leon any thoughts on the Colts backfield
going
forward yeah I just think you know
they're going to get a lot of high value
looks like this is a ground game that's
been efficient it's an offense that runs
really uptempo they've you know very
beginning of the year they were throwing
kind of a lot but last handful of weeks
they've been pretty run heavy so even
with two guys there there's a lot of
high value touches out of the back field
JT's got a nice playoff schedule to
three Dome games last one in your
championship week week 17 is going to be
home versus Las Vegas so that's another
little bonus in his favor I think you
could move like Derrick Henry or someone
for him yeah and running back Target
rate at mshu has spiked you know I mean
muu has been throwing to the running
back position both moss and Zach and
Jonathan Taylor a bunch second player to
trade for is one nobody wants to hear if
I say anything about Chris alave people
are like ah Adam what are you talking
about Chris alave stinks Derek Carr
stinks that narrative would be so
different if Chris alav didn't have a
football bounce off his face on what
would have been like a 50 yard touchdown
on Sunday literally wide open down the
sideline Carr hits him in the face and
it just bounces right off his helmet I
mean you wouldn't be able to trade for
Chris if he had just caught that and
scored now there's a lot of competition
on the Saints for targets but Chris has
still earned 25% of the targets and he
earns them downfield around the 14 yard
ADOT plays the Bears this week to me
like this is the time to trade for
chryst Buy Low you shouldn't have to
give up too too much right now before
the Bears game but I don't know I've
seen smart people also worried about
Chris olve here Leon so what do you
think about
him I mean I think it's a buy at worst
it would be kind of a hold situation for
me he's second behind only AJ Brown in
air yards this season he's got 1,50 AJ
Brown's at 193 they actually have very
similar expected Fantasy Point profil 77
targets for a la 83 for AJ Brown seven
Red Zone targets for La eight for AJ
Brown AJ Brown kind of uh you know an
alpha there he's a gam so it's not the
fairest comparison especially when you
have Jaylen Herz throwing you the ball
but the point being there's only four
players in the entire NFL with more than
900 air yards and A's up with 1,50 the
other two are Stefon Diggs and Tyreek
Hill so the quarterback plays not as
strong for a la as these other guys but
bottom line is you're G to start seeing
some spike weeks out of him the second
half of the Season that we didn't see in
the first half of the Season agreed
let's go back to the chat because we do
love our friends in the chat from
Detroit Irish he says Deontay Johnson or
Tony Pard this week oh Detroit Irish
you're bringing up you're bringing up
bad memories here uh Deontay Johnson bad
memories from roughly five days ago uh
I've been eating Ramen since Sunday
because I played a ton of Tony Pard in
DFS on
Sunday that
said his role remains really good he was
reason ably efficient similar to Chris
he had a screen pass that would have
gone for a touchdown bounce off of his
face mask in that
game Deontay Johnson's in a reasonable
spot too I think my lean would be pared
here but God I know it's painful right
now Leone has it come to this Deontay
Johnson or Tony Pard it's it's painful I
mean I'm still kind of firmly on Tony
Pard here I think you know the role in
the offense is too good I know Deontay
is in a good spot where his a DOT has
been better I actually think Deontay is
a pretty good trade Target um we've got
him on the list uh because you know his
ad dot has increased he's stepping into
the number one target share immediately
ahead of George Pickins but like
head-to-head with Tony Pard I'm on team
Pard I know people think like he's kind
of Dusty now he's not fully recovered
from his injury last season but as you
said like he dropped a screen pass like
that has nothing to do with his leg that
he like bobbled the screen pass at his
face mask so um you know it's it's G to
come for him you know we're gonna
and we're going to see just some TDS by
the go line because this off is good
enough toate those really strong
opportunities for Pard I I do think the
McCarthy stuff matters like Mike
McCarthy is undoubtedly not scheming to
Tony Pard strengths period but I would
still go P here over Deontay we'll have
more on Deontay here in a second Dominic
asked Kem hunt or my sanders this week
my sanders down bad I mean down real bad
he only played nine snaps last week
drone Ford is on the injury report again
for the Browns but creem hunt seems
relatively healthy my lean here is creem
hunt I mean you could run into a stone
Zero from my Sanders with chuba hubber
taking over this back field Leoni any
thoughts on Hunt vers
miles 100% with you on that one
Cleveland eight-point favorites they're
running ton of plays so even with Ford a
bit healthier this week if Hunt's the
number two I think they could just run
so much that you know both of them could
find the Box in this you know spot both
of them could see 10 plus carries so I
I'll take that for hunt on a team that's
expected to score as opposed to Carolina
where you know you know Black Shear was
playing more snaps than my sanders it
was real ugly as you mentioned I don't
know if this is a troll or not but Zach
asked Gus Edwards or Devonte Adams this
week I mean just think about this what's
going on here guys Gus Edwards likely
picked up off waivers or Devonte Adams a
consensus round one round two pick
I mean I get it on Gus Edwards I get he
scored three touchdowns I get Aiden
oconnell is starting for the Raiders
we're starting Devonte Adams here Le
only I don't think that uh you know I
don't think we need much analysis do
we no not you gotta go Devonte Adams um
it's just not close you know maybe if it
was a standard League it'd be somewhat
close but probably still Devonte Adams
and then Sam asks trade Cooper cup for
Chris alve you know I think Al's a a by
low guy probably not trading cup for him
I get the cup concern which is Stafford
might not play this week not fully
healthy then they have the bye but in
our rest of season top 150 we still have
cup you know meaningfully ahead of Ave
there's just so much upside like Al is a
good by low but cup if it breaks right
down the stretch could be a top five
fantasy guy and I don't think alve has
that type of upside in him so I'd
probably take on the Stafford risk and
keep cup yeah not giving up on Cooper
cup
all right let's get back to players to
trade for we already mentioned Jonathan
Taylor we mentioned Chris alve we'll
mention a guy that we just had a
question about Deontay Johnson I think
the biggest thing for Deontay Johnson is
one of the best Target earners in the
entire NFL no matter who his quarterback
is and his average depth of Target is
getting higher this year you know up to
12 13 14 yards which is way more than
it's been in the past and so when you
start earning a lot of targets at that
level of the field you start to find a
really really big ceiling and so I know
Deontay Johnson has not caught a
touchdown pass since literally the Ben
rothberger era but but I think that's
kind of noisy I mean it's not all noisy
the offense is obviously worse without
Ben rothberger at least you know before
final year Ben rothberger but I think
he's gonna find touchdowns so Deontay
Johnson will be one for me any thoughts
on that Leone then you can go to the
next one oh sorry we need to go 14
targets for Deontay Johnson week a 188
air yards that's a six or 13.4 8 out we
don't use usually see that out of him so
for him to sort of keep the ability to
earn a ton of targets but then start
seeing some of them downfield where you
get bigger plays you're going to see
those touchdowns uh I definitely think
it's a byow again you know he had a
pedestrian like eight for 85 game but it
could have been a lot more for
deont all right let's pause there and we
will go to our bundles presented by our
great friends at State
Farm first bundle and again bundles me
quarterback pass catcher or quarterback
running back combos that we like if you
guys play DFS if you play DFS
tournaments stacking is going to be a
big part of that you can check out more
on DFS stuff if you're interested on
establish the Run bundles for this week
will get to five of them first one is
one that a lot of people I think aren't
going to be on Taylor hinei is now the
starting quarterback for the Falcons
replacing an ineffective Desmond Ritter
Taylor hinek to Kyle pittz is
interesting now there's a lot going on
here as I said Desmond Ritter got
benched and Drake London is dealing with
a groin injury he's missed back-to-back
practices I don't know if he's going to
play this week hinei will be much more
accurate throwing the ball down the
field than Desmond Ritter was and Kyle
Pitts gets most of his targets deep down
the field so I'm always hesitant to get
excited about Kyle pittz he's let me
down so many times before and I do think
Minnesota's defense can play but I think
this is a pretty good spot any thoughts
on that one Leon then you can go to the
next
one yeah I just think HEI provides a bit
more upside down the field like you said
that we haven't seen out of Mariota and
Desmond Ritter the last couple years
which is great news for Pitts because
he's one of those tight ends that has a
higher ADI and can make some Splash
plays that a lot of other tight end
can't and he needs to because the
overall volume's not necessarily great
our second one is Mack Jones to Demario
Douglas uh this is definitely a good
value one in DFS this week and if you
look at the New England receiving corpse
right now there's just not much there in
terms of healthy bodies kind of BN we've
got out there Devonte Parker we've got
out there so we're projecting Demario
Douglas for over a 20% Target share this
week he was playing you know over 70% of
the routes last week playing a lot of
them in the slot the other guys that
have to get targets here are Jaylen
rager who's you know a huge bust and
then Juju Smith Schuster who seems like
he's complete dust at this point so
there's a possibility that dearo Douglas
earns 25% plus of the targets even more
than we're projecting which is already
at seven complete targets so I think
this is an interesting one where if Mack
has a good game it's going to be really
hard for Demario Douglas to not also
have a good game alongside him and
they're facing probably the best
possible matchup right now for offenses
I mean Not only was Washington like the
best matchup ever but now they just
traded away Chase young and montz sweat
at the deadline third bundle is going to
be Derek Carr to Alvin Cima this Cima
role for fantasy has been unreal you
know goal line work and such a high
volume of targets as Derek Carr checks
down so much now he gets the Bears you
know you don't have to play Carr with
chimra but I do think you capture some
of like the alive and Michael Thomas and
rashed Shahid big plays if you play Carr
with chimra so I think it's a bit
counterintuitive for people to play
quarterback with running back in the
case of guys like chimra it's certainly
makes sense any thoughts on that one
Leon then you can go to the fourth
bundle yeah also you know people kind of
look at this as a good matchup up for
the ground I think because of the spread
with New Orleans favored against pretty
bad quarterback but Chicago's run
defense has been you know much better
than their pass defense so I do think
there's some reason for even with New
Orleans possibly playing ahead here for
the pass game to be relying as you said
pass catcher to running back's totally
fine when the the running back can catch
10 plus balls we've already seen CRA do
that twice in four games and then I'll
go you know a HomeTown one here Josh
Allen to Gabe Davis against Cincinnati
really liked what I saw out of Buffalo
last week with do or with Dawson Knox
out they played more three wide receiver
stuff alen just seemed more comfortable
they had their highest pass rate OV
expectation of the entire season and
then Gabe Davis's role in particular
changed a lot with Kade playing tight
end and then playing three wide receiver
he had 12 targets previous high this
season was eight and it wasn't just like
crazy shots down the field they were
scheming a lot of shorter stuff to him
so I think when you combine that we know
he had has this big play Upside but now
the team has a bit more willingness to
scheme him some lower ADOT higher catch
rate targets the whole risk reward for
Gabe Davis starts to skew you know to
the to the reward side of the ledger so
I like this one quite a bit in the game
where both teams should be passing a ton
this week totally agree I mean people I
think discount how hard it is to be the
boundary wide receiver and succeed on a
consistent basis you know you're going
to see it tonight I'm afraid George
Pickin is just going to run go routes up
the sideline the whole game you see with
Michael Gallup it's so hard for him to
execute that and Gabe Davis that was his
role before but now with Dawson Knox out
he's getting more easy targets last
bundle Gardner
mshu and Michael Pitman against the
Panthers I'd be fine with Josh DS also
here but Pitman is earning more targets
than Josh DS and he's earning them
deeper down the field so you get a bit
of a bigger ceiling but you can
certainly throw the ball on the Panthers
I mean you can do whatever you want to
the Panthers but you can certainly
certainly certainly throw on them and as
Leone said this team is playing very
fast the Colts are not as throw heavy as
they've been were under Anthony
Richardson but playing very very fast
any thoughts on that one Leon before we
get to some chats here I mean as you
said you can pretty much do whatever you
want against the Panthers it's um you
know a spot against Carolina where the
Colts have a 23 team total it's going to
be one of their higher ones U not too
much more to add then I think it's a
good spot for the team overall and
Pitman is you know the the leader and
Target share there for the
Colts back to the chat our great friends
in chat Christian says what do you
expect from bejon Robinson this week so
everybody saw when bejon had the illness
or headache or whatever he had and he
barely played in that week seven game in
week eight his role was back to normal
now normal does not mean Workhorse
because we know Tyler alir is going to
play a ton of the base stuff normal role
for bean though is still good you know
if you can get 12 carries and five
targets from Bean which I think is very
reasonable that's still a really good
play for a player of his caliber not the
cleanest match up I don't think against
the Vikings much better defense Than
People realize but yeah any beon
thoughts this week
Leon yeah I like bejan this week we also
Atlanta's had a string of games too
where I I know people don't like to hear
it but they've kind of run bad in terms
of the game script for what they like to
do in terms of racking up tons of
running back touches and I think this
week they can get back to it as you know
roughly fivepoint home favorites playing
a backup quarterback for Minnesota and
jiren Hall you know where that could be
rough sliding so I really do like bejan
to bounce back this week and just
generally the second half of this season
I'm you my expectations are a lot higher
than the first
half um Devin says should I trade away
James Cook to get Kareem hunt so I'm
sure there's people out there that are
worried about the Leonard forette
signing in Buffalo my take on the
Leonard forette signing was that Damian
Harris
with that neck thing is probably going
to be out for a long time they needed
more bodies there my concern on forette
the only concern I on forette is that
historically he's been pretty good in
the pass game and I like when James Cook
gets some pass game work so there's some
concern on James Cook but I still think
I'd rather have him than Kareem hunt
Leone I think you'd probably agree on
there definitely I think Cook's role is
what it is it's not changing based on
Leonard fette you know the upsides
unfortunately somewhat Capp the way they
want to use them but I think the floor
as well is he's going to have you know
12ish carries a game he's going to be
pretty efficient he's going to be
somewhat involved in the past game you
just got to hope that he scores some
touchdowns from outside the 10 yard line
last question here Sean says Demario
Douglas or Michael Thomas this week so
certainly a good spot for Michael Thomas
against the Bears we already talked
about the spot for deir Douglas I'd be
shocked shocked if deir Douglas does not
get five six targets as a floor here in
this game against Washington
I think Michael Thomas gets five six
targets almost every week they're just
not that valuable I actually think I
might go Deary Douglas here Leone what
do you
think I'm gonna go Douglas I think
they're pretty close but I think there's
just some tal outcomes where Douglas has
a ton of targets given what they have
available at wide receiver I'd rather
you know roll the dice on the
uncertainty a little bit because I feel
like the floors are are pretty
similar all right let's get back to the
trades that we think you guys can make
that's the running back position on our
players to trade for list and we will go
with Joe Mixon now this one scares me a
little Leone because he's been so
inefficient for so long but man
certainly past the ey test against the
49ers looked really really spry in a
tough matchup last week I would note
that Chris Evans uh I'm sorry Chase
Brown who had been playing some pass
down stuff for them and mixing in he's
on IR now and so you get it's incredible
role for Mixon plays well in the pass
game efficiency always concerns me on
Mixon touchdowns always concern me but
yeah if somebody's giving him away here
for like fifth or sixth round value I
would be willing to ride with Joe Mixon
rest of season any thoughts on that one
Leon you can go to the next one
after yeah I would add to you know as
much as we like to pick on Mixon as
being an in efficient type player the
whole offense was inefficient to start
the year when Burl wasn't healthy and
that stuff always affects the running
back pretty directly even though we kind
of view the running back isolated from
the passing game so it's not totally
shocking with burrow healthy out of the
bye that Joe Mixon looked good when Joe
burrow looked a lot better and and if
you look at our running back DVP on
established to run Buffalo is one of the
more favorable matchups for opposing
running backs we saw Mixon take
advantage of that during the playoff
game last year so I think you'll have a
good good week this week I'll go to Jan
doson at number five and and he's
someone that you know sophomore wide
receivers in general are really good
breakout bets and Dawson was someone we
targeted early in the draft season but
it was a frustrating start to the year
last two weeks though he's seen eight
targets and 10 targets seen some Red
Zone looks we know we can find the end
zone and most importantly this
Washington team doesn't seem to be
letting up in terms of throwing the
football they have one of the highest
Pass rates over expectation of any team
in the NFL and it seems like regardless
of game script they're letting Sam Hall
air out so there's plenty of potential
for doson to get there even without
carving out a huge Target share on his
team it's so wild like Eric bemy came to
Washington and was like well I have Sam
Howell instead of patching Mahomes but
I'm still G to try to throw the ball 50
times a game it's just like a wild game
plan to have um but yeah you know I
think it's gotten more condensed lately
with between McClaren and doson which um
makes me more optimistic on him all
right last guy to trade for this one is
going to be controversial but TJ
hackinson now hear me out Kurt Cousins
is out for the year I would assume that
everyone in your league who has Vikings
is in full-blown panic I actually think
it'd be an interesting time to trade for
Justin Jefferson betting on Talent at
pass catcher position and kind of
blinding out everything else is
something that I like to do Josh dos has
shown an ability to get the ball to the
tight end Zack ZZ was having very usable
Fantasy games with Josh
dos um Trey McBride even last year had
some good games and obviously this past
week Trey McBride went completely nuked
so where T.J Hawkinson operates real
close to line of scrimmage I think fits
with Josh dos well not to say he'll do
better than he did with Kurt Cousins but
the perception that the Vikings pass
catchers are all dead I'm just not sure
I agree with that fully not dead
obviously worse but not dead so I think
it's an interesting time to try to get
an elite tight end because in the
playoffs man when you're if you're in
the fantasy playoffs like having an edge
of tight end is such a huge Advantage so
yeah any thoughts on hackinson going
forward here
Leone I think especially in full PPR
leagues like the volume should be there
the efficiency might not be great but uh
this is a team that I think will still
have you know somewhat of an aggressive
nature obviously not as aggressive as
they were under cook cousins but I don't
think they're just all of a sudden going
to turn into this like power running
football team so I'm with you and we
know hackinson value has taken a hit
it's just we don't think he's taken as
much of a hit as the market thinks he
does and that's the reason for trades
like this and you can still find
Opportunities even want a player is sort
of going in the wrong direction
overall all right let's recap our
players that we wanted to trade for here
Jonathan Taylor Chris
olave Deontay
Johnson Joe Mixon Johan doson and TJ
hackinson all right before we wrap up
here want to make sure we get to as many
chats questions as we can Manuel asks
Kyle pittz or Trey McBride this weekend
I love Trey McBride I've been drafting I
drafted a ton of Trey McBride and beste
ball type stuff um this will be one of
the hardest matchups he has all year
against the Browns so tough one here
Leon Pitts or
McBride I'm going to go pits I think the
uncertainty a lot of times like to
Target the uncertainty because there's
reward but I think in McBride's case
there's more risk than reward you
mentioned the matchup being poor you've
also got Clayton ton playing quarterback
um and we don't totally know what to
expect there um it's probably going to
be a downgrade from what we saw with
Josh dos so give me pits in a spot where
they're home favorites the team total is
pretty solid I think that's you know the
clear upside play between the two Norman
says who should I start this week CJ
strad or Joe Bur
such a big game for the Bengals they
have been so pass happy over the last 3
four weeks I don't think this one is
close we've seen strad kind of fall back
to Earth a little bit I thought strad
was in a really good spot last week
against Carolina and they went really
run heavy which surprised me so I think
this one is burrow and not particularly
close let's go to completely agree yeah
I was just going to go to the next I'll
go to Jorge who asks rashed Shahed or
chuba H hubard at Flex uh PPR League I
think it's got to be hubard it seemed
like he was the clear clear starter over
my sanders it's a pretty good matchup
against the Colts they've been allowing
a lot of fantasy points above
expectation to the running back position
I know Shahed went off last week but
he's very volatile he did all that only
on three catches you know and a couple
of those long balls if you don't catch
him uh the floor is very very shaky so
I'm gonna go hover there Jay Thomas says
would you give up Calvin Ridley to get
Aaron Jones I wouldn't man I'd rather
have Ridley because I'm worried that
this Packers offense is not going to get
a turned around what I've seen from
Jordan love Is Just worse than I even
imagined it could be um and so Aaron
Jones continues to deal with his
hamstring issue meanwhile I know
Ridley's been up and down is is a really
good offense and he's still earning a
ton of targets so I think Ridley over
Aaron Jones here for me assuming that
you have some running back
help BPW asks would you trade Mixon for
moster I think I'd rather have Mixon
here you know we hit on reasons why
mixon's a bu a low for mostard I'm
always kind of like worried about his
durability over the course of the season
and we've got Devon Anan at some point
coming back possibly during the playoff
stretch it's going to cut into things
Miami doesn't have the best playoff
schedule so you know it's an efficiency
versus volume thing I get why you might
prefer moster but mixon's you might
preferred back out of these two yeah I
think the big question is when will
Devon Anan be back cuz if you told me
aan was going to be out for the rest of
the year it would be most dirt for me
but I do think from the reports that
I've seen it seems like aan will be back
in the next one two three weeks or so
Jason says should I try to trade Pard
for Jonathan Taylor oh God more Pard
questions Leon they're trying to send me
into a deep and dark depression would
you give up Pard to get
JT uh dud call me a masochist but I
think I'm I've just made my bed with the
the Tony Pard stuff I'm I'm just I'm
taking that to zero okay we're going to
go on a crypto ride with Tony Pard who
is gonna stay on it until it goes to
zero so
um Tony paard for me I think I could be
dead wrong maybe he's dust you know I
definitely think he's lost a step
McCarthy's not scheming things well for
him they're running him up the middle
but I do think sometimes there's just
prolonged stretches where like just
doesn't quite happen and I think we
could get a prolonged stretch where it
does happen for par and I just think the
upsides better than Jonathan tayor yeah
I they've been in some weird games like
like blowouts I mean defensive
touchdowns they've won games by 40
points they've lost games by 30 points
they got into crazy obvious run
situations so not to make excuses for
the guy but he just hasn't had that many
clean setups or
schemes Dr says would you start a Cooper
or Josh DS this week of course we don't
know if deshun Watson's going to start
this week this current state of desan
Watson I'm not even sure is better than
PJ Walker regardless but yeah any
thoughts on that one
leam I mean I think I'm going Amari
Cooper you know kind of hit on how alve
has a ton of air yards and like you
might not expect it but Amari Cooper is
actually fifth in the NFL in aards 882
now I know when you're playing with
Watson and Walker some of those are
prair yards but as good as Josh DS has
been I think Cooper's just got a bit
more juice on the upside end of things
if you're looking for purely a floor
play I'd probably bet you know on DS's
reception volume being greater than
Amari Cooper's on a given week but I
think the talent outcomes favor Cooper
just a little bit more that I would
start him all right last one involves
Curtis Samuel who I
mean I know everybody probably hasn't
digested the injury report yet but I'm
worried about Curtis Samuel Health Dylan
S Romeo dobs or Curtis Samuel Curtis
Samuel came into last week with an
injury and then seemed to hurt or
aggravate his toe hasn't even practiced
yet this week so even if Curtis Sim ends
up suiting up here I'd probably just go
dos on the health side here and kind of
ignore everything else just kind of
stinks for Curtis Samuel he was carving
out a pretty good role but this goes
back to the Johan doson stuff where the
less that Cur s is involved the better
it is for Jan doson all right that is
going to do it for this week nine
Bleacher Report fantasy football show
presented by State Farm if you're
interested in more content like this you
can head to establish run.com be sure
you're following both me and Michael and
Bleacher Report on Twitter our name or
at least my name all one word Leone had
to make it hard for everyone two hats
One mic for Leone on the Twitter machine
four Leon four all our friends at State
Farm everyone behind the scenes I'll
beat your report I am Adam good luck
everybody